♪ ♪
>> TUCKER CARLSON SHOWING THIS
SOFT CRIME POLICIES RUINING THE
SECOND BIGGEST CITIES.
THE SUICIDE OF LOS ANLES IS
STREAMING RIGHT NOW AND
FOX NATION HERE'S A PREVIEW.
>> NEVER SOUGHT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY DESPAIR.
>> HE'S AN ACT AND A LONGTIME
REDENT OF LOS ANGELES.
HE MOVED OUT AFTER HIS HOME WAS
BURGLARID TWICE.
>> HE WA THE DISTRICT ATTNEY
AND HE DESTROYED SAM'S DISCO.
AND NOW MOVING TO LOS ANGELES SO
HE CAN DESTROY LOS ANGELES.
♪ ♪
>> THE COMMON LOS ANGELES BECOM.
>> THERE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOME SECURITY AND HOW TO
KEEP YOURSELF SAFE.
>> THEY BURGLARIZED MY HOUSE A
COUPLE OF TIMES.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE CRIMINALS WHO
BURGLARIZED YOUR HOUSE?
NO,OT YET.
>> TUCKER JOAN JUST RIGHT NOW TO
TELL US MORE TUCKER ABOUT THE
SPECIAL WAS VERY APTLY NAMED
SAYING IT'S THE SUICIDE OF
LOS ANGELES CONSIDERING THAT
GEORGE WAS VOTED INTO.
>> THAT'S RIG.
IT WAS AN INTENTIONAL ACT HUGE
CITY IT'S A VERY COMPLICATE IT
CITY IT'S CITY THAT'S CHANGED A
LOT SO THERE'S A LOT OF CAUSES
FOR E DISORDER THAT YOUEE
BUT THE MAIN ONE IS RELY EASY
TO TRACE.
THERE IS THE MAIN PROSECUTOR IN
TH CITY OF L ANGELES STOP
PROSECUTING VIOLENTRIMES.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GUESS ABOUT
WHAT CAN HAPPEN WE KNEW IT WAS
GONNA HAPPEN HE DID IT ANYWAY.
AN AWFUL LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE DIED
THIS IS AN ACT OF CRUELTY WHICH
SAID THAT OUT LOUD.
>> Jeanine: HAVING A
PROSECUTOR WHO IS WOKE IS ALMOST
WORSE THAN HAVING A OSECUTOR
AT ALL.
BECAUSE WHAT HES DOING IS HE'S
LETTING PEOPLE OUT OF JAIL HAD A
TIME AND OBVIOUSLY DO NOT ADDING
ANKIND OF SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES AS YOU CALL I
FORM TRYING TO THINK IS WHO HAS
THE MOST LEVERAGE HERE?ARE THE E
COMMUNITY PEOPLE THATIGHT HAVE
LEVERAGE?
THEN ULTIMATELY THAT THEY NEED
VOTES.
>> THIS KIND OF IMMORAL AME
THAT'S PARALYZED SKEHOLDERS IN
LOS ANGELES.
YOU'RE A BAD PERSON IF YOU ARE
AGAINST ALLOWING VIOLENTCRIMINAT
CRIMES.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS LONG-TERM
IS NOT THAA LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
DIED AND ARE DYING NOW PROBABLY
AS W SPEAK.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THIS IS THE
END OF THE WHOLE SYSTEM.
PRECUTORS ON ONE SIDE OF THE
FENCE ATTORNEY AS YOU KNOW.
WHICH OF THE PROSECUTOR AND THE
DEFENSE ATTORNEY ANDOU DRIVE
PEOPLE TO SELF-DEFENSE THE
VIGILANTE JUSCE.
PEOPLE CAN'T COUNT ON THE STATE
TO PROTECT THEMHEY WILL
PROTECT THEMSELVES BECAUSE
PEOPLE WL PROTECT THEIR
FAMILIES AND YOU START TO SEE
EXTRAJUDICIAL KILLINGS IN
LOS ANGELES.
>> Jeanine: THE CAL
RITTENHOUSE EFFECT.
>> IT'S ICU TUCKER.
AS YOU WENT THRGH THIS DID YOUWS
THAT THEY SHOULD BE PURSUING.
I KNOW THAT THOSE ARE GUNS OFF
THE STREET.
WANT MORE COPS ON THE STREET I
AGREE WITH YOU THAT WE HAVE TO
PROSECUTE CRIMES AND ITEEMS
LIKE THEY'RE FACING SOME
POLITICAL PRESSURES.
BUT ARE THERE OER IDEAS OUT OF
THAT THAT YOUR REPORTING  YOUR
SERIES TT IS REVEALED?
>> THIS IS A REALLY SPACE TRAVEL
IS THE STUFF THAT HUMAN BEINGS
HAVE DEALT WH SINCE THEY LEFT
THE CASE OR EVEN BEFORE.
HOW DO YOU DETER FROM THE PEOPL
LIVING WITH YOU AND YOU PUNISH
THEM IF YOUO YOU PUNISH SOME
SWIFT AND CERTAIN SKULL
DETERRENCE.
TO DO WITH YOUR KIDS DWITHYOUR L
LIVING THINGS LEARN.
SO WE KNOW WHAT TO DO JUSTENFORC
CREATES BY LEARNING.
IT'S LIKE RESTORING WHAT WE HAVE
AND THINGS WILL BFINE.
THAT'S THE ANSWE.
>> TUCKE WE CAN SEE THE
CONSEQUENCES AND WE SOUGHT A
PART OF YOUR SEGMENT IHINK THE
QUESTION IS WHY IS THIS
HAPPENING, WHY IS HE DOING THIS?
IF YOU DON'T HAVE RULE OF LAW
YOU'VE DEGRADATION OF SOCTY
YOU DON'T HAVE A COUNTRY IF YOU
DON'T HAVE RULE OF LAW AND IS A
GEORGE SOROS FUNDED PROSECUTOR
IT'S US WHAT'S DESTROYING
AMERICA THIS IS ABOUT JUSTICE IS
IT?
>> IT'S ABOUT PUNISHMENT.
ALL OF THIS UNDER HELPING THE
UNDERDOG THERE TO GET WHAT'S
COMING TO THEM.
YOU CAN, SUPPORT IT MAY BE.
THERE'S A LOT IAVE NOT THIS
COUNTRY.
MOST THE TIME OF THE SIDE.
THEY'RE NOT BENEFITING
THEY'RE NOT BENEFITING IT ALL.
IN FACT THERE THE MAIN VICTIMS
IN THIS.
THE POINT OF THIS IS  PUNISH
THE HS.
THIS IS AN ACT OF AGGRESSION
AGAINST THE STAKEHOLDERS IN
LOS ANLES AND CHICAGO NEW YK
THIS IS TRYING TO HURT PEOPLE
NOT HELP THEM.
I WISH PEOPLE WOULD JUSSAY
THAT BECAUSE SO VERY OBVIOUS.
>> Greg: HATE TKER I'VE GOT
TWO QUESTIONS FOR YOU NUMBER
ONE, QUITE OBVIOUSLY IRAN
FOX NATION THIS IS A SPECIAL
IT'S A STREAMING SUCCESS.
NOW THAT CNN PLUS IS DEFUNCT AS
FOX NATION CONSIDERED WE HIRI
CHRIS WALLACE FOR FOX NATION
WITH THE PROBABLY GETIM AT
DISCOUNT I SEENHAT HE
INTERVIEWS A LOT OF VE
INTERESTING PEOPLE.
AT'S MY FIRST QUESTION.
>> BETA MEETING ABOUT THIS IN MY
OFFICE.
HE JUST FLED THEM ON MY
PRODERS GO HE'S MIKE WALLACE'S
SO[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: SO I WANT TO A
ABOUT THERE IS SOME HOPE IN
CALIFORNIA I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING
AND TALKG TO MICHAEL
ELLENBERGER I WAS WONDERING
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS WER HE'S
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR AGAST
GAVIN NEWSOM.
'S UNUSUAL AND THE FACT THAT
HE ALREADY HAS DELUSIONS WHICH
IS QUITE RARE.
>> WHAT AN INTERESTING SMAR G
GUY.
ACTUALLY HAS THE MOST REVEALG
DOCUMENTARY SERIES OF EVEREEN
ON HOMELESSNESS EVER EXPLAINS.
FROM A CALIFORNIA SUMMARYEOPLE
JUST GIVE UP AND LEFT WAS YOU
AND ME AND LIKE MILLIONOF
OTHERS LIKE US IN THE STATE.
AS PEOPLE AT SLLENBERGER WHO
WERE STANG AND FIGHTING TO
IMPROVE AND RECLAIM IT.
THEY'RE GONNA SAVE THE STATE ARM
OF THE STRONGLY.
>> IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU TUCKERG
AMICANS THIS CRUCIAL REPTING
AND ALLOCATION OF WHAT'S GOING
ON THANK YOU.
GREAT T